hello there issue four of marvel and
fortnite's crossover series is here the
zero war has taken us from reality zero
and on to earth 616. our spider-man and
his crew are tasked with tracking down
the lost shard of the zero point taken
by galactus last issue that shard was
combined with antarctic vibranium and
stolen by doctor doom who then escaped
back to our island so in this issue it's
back to reality zero we go my name is
adam maru which is also my creator code
if you'd be so kind issue four zero war
let's go
spider-man jones the imagined and
wolverine leave the savage lands and
return to the island using the portal
device to pursue victor von doom along
with shuri who has never been here
before she immediately asks why it's so
cold here and that's for good reason
they have not traveled to the island
itself rather they're on the ice moon
orbiting the zero point thankfully thor
and storm have made these sub-freezing
temperatures survivable but only barely
on their mission to find the mech
luckily the imagined uses an invisible
force field to keep everyone safe nice
bit of plot armor but it won't last
forever back on mission wolverine uses
his real superpower smell
to locate molten metal which leads the
team to an ancient castle a doorway has
been melted into the walls arctic
vibranium is near inside beings are kept
on display it's kind of like marvel's
collector they look to be in some sort
of stasis the last time we saw something
like this we try to unvolt a drum gun
agent jones finds the owner of the
frozen castle sat on his throne it's the
ice king completely still frozen in
place he's the man behind arguably the
worst live event in fortnite history
when he froze the entire island and
luckily we're about to get some lore on
that as jonesy steps forward he triggers
something a hologram-like summon stands
before them and is the ice king he tells
us he once had another name but now he
prefers to use ice king his task in life
is to collect items of power items that
could reshape reality and therefore are
too dangerous to exist the law comes
thick and fast now as the ice king tells
us why the prisoner was trapped in the
dungeons back in chapter one cast your
mind back the prisoner was a former ally
a friend who became intrigued by using
the objects of power to change reality
to their liking the ice king is
uncorruptable and immediately he throws
his friend in place because he could no
longer be trusted he was being corrupted
by power no second chances here frozen
forever in time and space
[Music]
the ice king brought the ice moon to
reality zero in the hopes of it
remaining isolated and safe away from
everyone else the ice king then fell
into an eternal sleep protecting all
realities from items that could change
the laws of nature we know that didn't
go to plan part of the moon sheared off
in a storm and splashed down in the
ocean below slowly floating closer and
closer until it became a part of our
world he didn't tell us why hench santa
claus was riding it though that's a
story for another time what
the heat eventually melted this biome
and both the ice king and the prisoner
awoke they commenced battle once again
unleashing strange beings on the island
like zombie snowmen and ninja lizards
fortnight was weird back then
and that also gave us the devourer
eventually the ice king prevailed once
again freezing his former friend in
water this time below the island which
means he could still be there right now
waiting for his chance to awake
preoccupied by this war with the
prisoner the ice king did not see the
devourer's attempt to take out the zero
point luckily we know the paradigm and
io joined forces to sort out that little
problem for him
the ice king returned to the moon and
made the temperature so hostile no one
could survive yet standing in front of
him are our five heroes and he hits us
with a bombshell like no other your
presence here proves you are too
dangerous to remain free for the good of
the omniverse you will abide with me as
part of my collection the group are
shocked they are now prisoners on the
ice moon the temperature begins to drop
they are slowly freezing into stasis or
death i'll let you decide everyone on
the moon will soon meet their end the
group no time is against them they must
complete their mission to find doctor
doom and the zero point shard the
paradigm realizes the foundation and his
team are on the moon as temperatures
drop she radios in get off the moon we
cut to the foundation we are kind of in
the middle of something imagined
they've done it they've rebuilt the mech
standing in all its glory hey they even
found a new arm for it all they need is
the zero point shard to bring all
systems back online we jump back to the
imagined as they finally catch up with
doctor doom the shard is within touching
distance tactics go out the window they
charge the man in green but doom is a
much stronger foe than they faced before
and with new weapons in tow our heroes
stand no chance yet their sheer numbers
and random nature of attacks could see
them win spider-man takes doom shield
wolverine goes up and close with claw
attacks jones gets a new weapon from one
of those stasis pillars can they do this
no no not a chance doom gets a little
mad now and uses an explosion of energy
like he's going super saiyan to force
them all back he lifts the zero point
shard and if you're wondering what sound
that makes it's fwoosh
very thwoosh sure he screams he's
figured out how to use the zero shard we
can't stand up to that luckily shuri was
planning for this scenario and forced
herself close enough to reveal her plan
shuri has a piece of tech which renders
all antarctic vibranium inert one click
and it's gone and that's enough time for
spidey to jump in and take back the zero
shot
[Music]
if you're wondering how shuri knew to do
this that story is in marvel's doom war
dr doom in that storyline found a way to
channel the energy of vibranium and the
only way to charla could beat him was by
destroying all processed vibranium on
the planet all earth 616's vibranium was
made inert useless and wakanda became
bankrupt overnight but that's not the
story we're reading now let's get back
to fortnite
spider-man now has one job to reach the
mech before the snowstorm ends his life
as the seconds and minutes pass by the
four remaining heroes facing doom are
out of ideas and charge into battle one
last time knowing this is likely the end
and every single one of them are
defeated by doom he is superior and we
know he has better onomatopoeias too
like choom and shekau
in true bad guy fashion doctor doom
takes too long to end our heroes and the
moment he's about to do it a huge crash
is heard behind him spider-man has done
it he made it back to the mech and it's
here to stop this super villain never to
be perturbed doom thinks fast and
delivers one last line before escaping
then i need waste no more time here the
final battle will occur on the island we
will meet again there
[Music]
they had done it the two groups had
fulfilled their tasks to fix the mech
and to power it back up using the zero
shard now piloting the mech again
paradigm reassures the imagined that she
isn't a double agent we've already
covered that in a previous issue already
before the group can celebrate the ice
king's castle crumbles behind them as
they head back to the island the zero
war is about to end and that's where the
issue ends so one issue to go and i
can't wait to see what happens next the
mech all our heroes and dr doom are all
coming to the island i'll see you next
month for the final part in this issue
thank you so much if you used my code
you made this video possible much
appreciated i'm adam you're awesome i'll
see you next time
[Music]
you